Episode 206 was the start of a very
interesting emotional
arc for me.
I think that often times,
African American women
in corporate environments
are tokenized
and they are taken
advantage of, because
they need help to
get up the ladder.
I can see you’re
obviously hurting.
Can you see that, Chip?
I think Karen Pittman portrays
her with such magnificence
that you can see the pain,
you can see the complexity,
and you can see her struggle.
I trust you will
do the right thing,
that you won’t let your
personal involvement
cloud your judgement?
During this time
there was an undeniable
new anti-Asian sentiment
that was happening.
It was uncomfortable
to talk about, but
I was grateful that we
were able to incorporate
it and talk about it with
a level of care and dexterity
in terms of how we
were gonna present this.
Can you get me pictures or not?
One of the most
interesting things
that the show attempts to do is
wrestle with the idea
of just how hard it is
to be an adult in a world where
the foundations are
shifting all the time.
I love Cory’s moral ambiguity,
he does some of the most
incredible, selfless things.
He does some of the
most horrible things
and he does them
with equal enthusiasm.
He’s a strategist, and I think
when his strategy doesn’t
work he pivots quickly.
Someone being outed,
against their will.
This is not about being outed.
When Laura leaves
Bradley’s dressing room,
she turns around
and says to her,
“And you’re right,
it’s wrong what happened"
The first time I said
the line I thought
I’m gonna cry and
I don’t wanna cry here
it’s not my scene,
this is her scene
but I realized when I actually
verbalized those lines
it’s just the worst feeling
you could ever have.
Mom’s been calling,
she’s embarrassed!
I think there are
a lot of people
who are very constrained
by their upbringing.
I see, Bradley growing
in this moment
and slowly pulling herself away
from a family that tried to
define her with
very narrow terms.
I have a lot of
clarity right now.
In this season, there’s
a lot of self-examination.
Who are they?
What matters?
And we question that a lot
through our characters.